Ah, ah, ah, ah.
Moe, moe, boo!
Oka-ee-nasaimasu!
Go-shu-jinsama!
Sorry, hold on.
I'm okay!
Hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello, hello.
Hello, hello, hello, hello.
Welcome back.
Did this screen change again?
Hold on, I'm keeping an eye on Johnny.
What are you doing sitting over there?
I just gave him a snack.
Sometimes he has post-food zoomies.
Right now he seems okay.
I think the screen changed.
I remember the title screen being blue.
Not...
Red.
The biohazard thing?
Is new?
What biohazard thing?
feel pretty red.
Right.
Yeah, whose office is this?
I wonder if this is big jam.
Upcoming DLC in the corner.
Oh!
Ha ha ha!
Wait, is this out?
This biohazard?
Is this out?
TV Table Trade!
Thank you so much for the time gifted!
I hope you guys are having a great week so far.
Hello, Hello, I hope you guys are having a great day!
If this is your first time seeing crime scene cleaner,
there's a bit of a story, but also it's not super heavy
story, so you can just kind of join, jump in.
We're a crime scene cleaner, we're Kovalski, we work for a
guy named Big Jim, and we're cleaning up crime scene places
to save money for our daughter who is sick.
That's about it.
hours until fall.
It's good.
Just watch the new Resident Evil movie yesterday.
I quite liked it.
I heard good things.
Actually, I heard mixed things, but I also heard good
things.
I want to see it real bad, though.
Because I heard it's fine.
I heard it's really good.
It's so good.
You liked it.
I heard the thing about it not being a Resident Evil movie.
But I'm also, like, curious.
Best horror movie I've seen in theaters, really.
I mean, considering the previous one we did get.
Don't dislike the premise of it being some rando.
You know what I mean?
Like, I'm not the type of person.
Even if it's like...
I'm trying to think of like a series but I don't dislike
that idea so I think it's quite yeah like it's a side story
in the universe I think that's quite fun so I do want to see
it Konminto
Ethan Winters was a random and he's gotten a lot of love now
exactly exactly yeah Ethan was That's some rando, too.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, exactly.
I don't think, you know, I mean, I'm for both sides.
I love a movie that's full of fan service.
Or, like, you know, just a thing that's full of fan service.
You know, like Metal Gear Solid 4.
So I understand if they're like, I just wanted to see Leon
Kennedy.
But I'm also a big fan of just like a side story kind of
random thing.
Hmm.
What was that, Johnny?
What was that?
Standalones are nice.
I agree.
But yeah, no spoilers in the movie, obviously.
No spoilers, don't even say, don't even, so there's probably
people that are, not probably, but there are definitely
people that are bigger Resident Evil fans than I, that have
not seen it yet, so we should not spoil what sort of cameos
or Or little eggs.
What's the word?
Egg?
Easter egg!
There are.
Spoiler, the residents are evil.
Yeah, don't tell anybody what eggs are in the movie.
But I think today will be quite long.
So, oh my gosh, and also the Silent Hill came out today.
I'm quite curious about it.
Don't spoil the obelisk.
Yeah, exactly.
To me, fan service is okay, but the movie has to have
substance.
Like the Mario Galaxy movie, not having enough substance.
That's quite literally why I have not watched it yet.
I heard that Rosalina gets very little screen time, and I
was like, I'm out.
What do you mean?
Rosalina gets, like, five minutes of screen time.
Ari movies come in three flavors.
One, the old Alice ones that are, yeah.
The CGI movies that are our canon to the Resident Evil
timeline that are mixed at best.
This new one.
I mean, I feel like we've seen, it's the CGI movies.
game series are nothing new.
We've seen it with Final Fantasy.
There is an evil movie in my local regal cinema, but I have
nobody to watch it with.
Just go by yourself.
Go by yourself.
You don't have to...
I mean, obviously it might be more fun, but...
Don't deny yourself of a pleasure because you are by
yourself.
Hmm.
Fox gets more screen time.
That rose and light up!
take yourself on a date decorate a mannequin and be like
this is my date does she need a ticket or he whatever you're
into you can hoard the popcorn by yourself I know that like
popcorn buckets are getting a little overdone but some of
them are so fun still Like, did you guys see Gyle's hair?
I thought that one was pretty, pretty, pretty silly.
I really liked that one.
The Gyle bucket.
Yes, yeah.
They can't make, I just can't dislike them.
I can't.
There's some of them, some of them I'm like, this is not,
this is just, this is not a popcorn bucket.
This is not.
But that one is really good.
I feel like, I feel like they only blew up.
much because of the high or the hype controversy the the
discussion of the dune one you know what i mean everybody
was so like oh you you guys got that dune bucket the super
girl one was gross wait i don't know it super girl popcorn
bucket wait what's wrong was it wait the alien one
I'm seeing a space hog.
Maybe I'm not seeing the right one.
There's one...
Oh, that's it for a drink.
I'm not seeing that.
It's, um...
Because it has a jacket on it.
Wait, is it because of the jacket?
The back of it is very flesh-colored.
Wait.
But that's...
That's a drink holder.
Right?
The jacket looks like skin.
It does.
It's quite flesh colored.
I will admit.
Maybe they...
It does look pretty...
It does look kind of wrong.
Ew.
The more I look at it, the worse it looks.
It looks like someone...
It looks like it should have been a cup holder for Silence
of the Lambs or something.
It rubs the lotion on its skin.
What the heck?
That's gross.
Okay, I get it now.
Oh.
You know Supergirl, always wearing that skirt.
Yeah, exactly.
She's known for the skin jacket.
Everybody...
Everybody agrees.
But let's get into...
Yeah, I'm curious about...
I'm curious about Silent, New Silent Hill.
Especially because they showed like nothing of the game
beforehand.
So I'm very like, what's going on?
What was I doing?
Great question!
Oh no, we missed like the whole intro bit.
Ah, okay, well, that's fine.
Oh, not that.
Where's my...
Here we go.
My skill tree.
I think everything is...
I think everything has been...
What was I doing?
I don't know.
Johnny, are you gone?
Okay.
Supposedly Townfall has the hardest puzzles.
That's kind of fun.
I've seen, from what I've seen of it, because I did watch,
like, some streamer playing it earlier.
I need to open it from the other side.
It feels a little bit more like, um...
Like, very...
Like, you know, uh...
Silent Hill F was very combat heavy.
This feels the exact opposite.
From what I'm seeing.
But...
I don't know.
Maybe I'll play it sometime.
you kind of skipped what big jim was saying at the beginning
yeah i missed it i'm sorry guys i wonder if i could like
restart the mission let's see if it works we didn't do
anything so i think it's okay friendship heavy the moment
when big jim was at his weakest with so many people going
after his ass he needed to make a choice if not there
probably wouldn't be anything else to i'm here oh here we go
now listen the power is down so find a way to turn it back
on it will help you a lot with your powers down okay
obviously
oh man next to cleaner i should definitely add electrician
to my cb
oh boy no need to look for the bodies it begins okay all
righty i'm gonna start putting down first and things like
that so we're just gonna initializing process of well
refreshing the air what the wow we're just gonna start out a
start out on this hatch if I can get it open what hatch this
hatch oh okay um let's go around they spare no one he says
tall first floor
Oh, no!
This guy...
Looks like an access card.
Convair belt key.
That seems like something.
Can't do it without the electricity.
No, I can't do it.
Oh, golly.
Alright.
There's a lot of stuff here, too.
Sorting room.
Ara.
Okay.
Just kidding?
Um.
Container lot.
Anything in here?
Yoink.
Uh.
So finding the power.
How to turn on the power is our first job.
Wisto.
Thank you very much here.
I'll just start bagging some stuff anyway.
Why not?
Thank you.
Oh,
gosh, okay.
Whoa!
Yoink!
Stuff that in my pocket.
Control room.
Purple for lights.
Purple for...
Yellow for crane.
Uh...
Oh!
they're they're also doing something oh I have the access
card
so green was what fast belt okay so that's open now oh
manual hacking wait oh shoot I forgot how to do this nice
wait Done.
I'm in.
Hacker voice.
Oh, we got blue?
Another one.
Place is already humongous.
Use maximum of three panels at one time.
I almost did not.
This is blue is what?
Hatches.
I'm so in.
Oh my god!
here's something like boiling well today is my turn johnny
why is everybody named john johnny week one john week two
john week three john week four john johnny john johnny it's
johnny i didn't know he had a part-time job my little boy
he's so he's so capable
Breakroom?
Can I, like, start turning lights on then because I have the
power on or something?
There's lots of blood here, but no...
No, uh...
What's the word?
Do I have to clean up all this trash?
Oh my gosh, I do.
There's no body.
Movie nights every Friday.
Mandatory.
Relaxing oz!
Movie first, later more movies.
Bring snacks.
We gather at the old TV room above the power supply.
F you, John!
Alright, no thank you!
It's so quiet.
I haven't even found where I can put my...
My...
Wait, where's the body?
I found him.
Where I can put my bucket, you know?
Oh, wait.
What is that?
Not quite sure.
Alrighty.
Let's activate this thing.
What?
Wait, did I not?
Wait, what did...
How did I do it wrong?
I returned to Min playing Crime Scene Cleeter, and she's
doing probably the longest, most complicated level of the
game.
Good luck, Miss Phantom.
Thank you!
Yeah, it is...
Wait, maybe I follow whatever that is.
It's a doozy.
Maybe it's whatever this...
It's got layers.
Like an onion.
Okay, Shrek.
Oh, shoot.
How do I get back down?
Oh, wait, we can go from here.
And then all the way down.
Where is it telling me to go?
I'm so confused.
Power supply.
Here.
The power switch should be around here somewhere.
Here we go.
I did it!
Punch!
Oh, come on.
Do I have...
Yes!
I still have my katana, this is great.
This is great, this is great.
The vents look cleaner in the movies.
Okay.
Punch!
Heya!
Wea!
Secret!
Oh my gosh, this guy is here too, the plant man.
Don't forget to water the plants and yourself!
He's quite literally everywhere.
He's got...
Wee-wee!
Would janitor assistant Jesse be good at this job?
I think she would complain a lot, I'm not gonna lie.
This job is the best.
Nothing out of the ordinary ever happens.
So I have a lot spare time to take care of my plants.
Thanks for believing me.
Now, I have to go for a quick round to give off the
impression of a very busy person.
See you soon, ma'am.
Ma'am?
Nothing out of the ordinary ever happens.
Truly.
Oh, y'all ink.
It pays to...
Pays to explore, everybody.
It also pays to steal.
Pays the bills.
Where are we here?
Oh!
Oh, wait.
There's...
This is my car!
We found the way around.
Okay.
A little bit of a shortcut.
Do I have to clean this?
Mint, girl, it was up.
Who's up?
Wait, is this my car?
This is my car, isn't it?
Who's up?
Can't leave while I'm still on the clock.
Oh, that was my car.
Oh, oh, oh, that scared me.
I was like, how did I get all these boxes in my car?
Oh my god, the bodies are just falling into it.
Oh, yeah.
They just fall.
into my lap.
That scared the heck out of me though.
Beautiful.
Okay.
Everything be working now.
Or should be working now.
We got Garbo.
I still don't know where I can put my bucket and such.
But we'll figure though what happened in here.
Golly.
On the They wanted to grab some things and run away.
Had the whole escape planned.
Pack the paintings into the truck.
On top of that, they wanted to steal my stuff.
What counts?
The bouncing boxes are pretty pretty.
This will be our escape and last payment.
And please use this money for a fresh start.
I'm on it.
Me do.
The man needed to pay for rent.
They ended up paying with his own life.
Can I put him on the conveyor?
Well, here we go.
Oh.
Dang it.
Wait, not me, not me.
Oh, sorry.
Release!
There you go.
Let's watch it happen.
He's like, no, no, please!
No, no, don't send me down there!
No, I can change, I can change!
That must be one of big gems, guys.
Are you going to beg for your life?
He's got the splits.
Okay, let's...
Oh, wait, there's this guy, too.
What could possibly happen that made them so desperate?
I wonder.
I wonder, too.
Because it's involving the guy we're having to work with,
no?
No.
Give me a new enemy.
Okay, hold on.
Well armed, you're a worker.
I think I saw...
Oh, okay.
They're all going.
Nice, very good.
I could have swore I've seen a thing for washing my buckets.
But now I don't know.
I think I imagined it.
Oh, more...
bullets i saw one too yeah right it like appeared and
disappeared she's sweet i thought you guys would have
noticed i didn't comment on it because i thought you
wouldn't notice me saying it maybe in here
i know no fear
wait hold on water supply colorful box aha all right we do
our this place is humongous so we're gonna have to like you
know i i've got pretty comfortable toilets straight from
jail how do i sign up for the revolution i've gotten pretty
comfortable like you know the game is so cozy i didn't mind
like being a little like inefficient in some of my ways but
i feel we'll want to be much more efficient for this for
this map
the uh optimal way of doing it yeah we have like three
buckets so we'll have one
the toilet paper it was in the toilet already of course the
toilet paper was gonna be wet
this map honestly isn't that bad i think the museum is worse
you think so well i mean well it doesn't seem so bad it just
seems quite large so far i don't know if i've There's 13
bodies.
Um, okay.
Detergence.
I had gotten a skill for the detergents.
Increase the power.
Wait, I did the increase the power of detergents.
So, we'll do.
Slow down the way which tools get stained.
That would be probably pretty good on this map.
So we're not having to run around so much.
Increases tool ability to clean difficult stains by 20.
Increases tool resistance by 20 and cleaning area by 20.
Detergent that increases washing surface by 30.
Slows down the rate at which water and bucket gets stained.
We'll do the strength.
Oh wait, I can do one more!
That's right.
Tool resistance and cleaning area.
We'll do that one.
Yes, yes, yes, all right.
Well, let's just get this real quick as we're here.
Oh, and my sponges too.
I can't remember at all the, uh...
Oh wait, I didn't even...
Hold on.
I didn't even dip it in.
I didn't even dip it in, silly me!
Okay, here we go.
All right.
Oh my god!
I didn't even know what you were talking about at first!
No one said yes, he didn't respond, so I think we're safe,
probably.
Check out that cleaning action.
Oh yeah, oh yeah, oh yeah.
What was my sense?
Oh yeah.
Oh, we do have to get these, huh?
Ugh.
Oh yeah, how's your guys' week been so far?
Hopefully good.
Oh, there's a guy there too.
Oh my god.
Completely flattened.
These workers really didn't put up some fight.
Completely flattened, huh?
No, no, please don't send me down the conveyor belt.
No, I have a wife and a kid.
Please, no, no, you're going downtown.
And by down, really downtown.
Oh, come on.
We'll get him later.
Oh, let's grab our funny guy here.
We'll stick him over here.
I'm stuck.
It's time for a purge.
Nah, it's not the bobble, it's not the conveyor belt making
them bobblehead.
They're still alive, and they're desperate to live.
Three.
There's a lot of meantime merch from Bexpo I need to sort
and set up.
Oh, please take a picture after I'd love to see.
I'd love to see.
Please, please, please.
bad because I didn't get to do much about around Vexpo, so
I'm kind of sad.
I felt a little fomal.
Rageile.
Yes, yes.
Why is the jukebox whispering demonic things?
It's my little demon from hell.
Well, you have a problem with demons?
If I were a demon, would you still like me?
Let me be honest.
What if one day I just...
I became a demon?
Yeah?
Wait, which one was it?
This one?
Maybe.
Wait, do I have double sponge?
What?
Okay.
What kind of a demon?
Hmm.
Wait.
I don't think I squeegeed this one.
Hello, hello!
Wait, okay, nice.
There we go.
Mint took in the hiss.
Orange peel!
Oh no, I do have to get these and put them back, don't I?
Oh, you evil, evil game.
How dare you, you evil, evil game.
him saying that was foreshadowing oh man
to the foul germs to the foul germs what even the paint oh
come on what if there was just an incident sorry he's
spooked me it's got me he got me he got me Oh, there's still
blood here.
So did he die and then run over the other dude?
That's pretty unfortunate.
He says, no, I didn't do it.
I'm innocent.
I swear.
Someone take his fork.
He...
I don't believe he was forklift certified.
I'll say it.
I don't think he was forklift certified.
Alright.
We will take buckets around.
around.
I don't think we need to right now at the risk of
potentially, um, you know, potentially spilling them.
But this area is not that big, luckily, so I think we're...
Oh, look at that, look at...
Oh, oops.
Look at the area coverage.
Yeah, baby.
Do I have to move this thing back?
We have to drive the...
I'm not forklift certified!
What if I...
What if I get into an incident?
I know no sir.
Now I am.
You think so?
Am I ready?
Am I ready to be?
Forklift certified?
Am I ready?
The maid is cleaning.
I do.
I do my maid is cleaning.
duties no I'm not sadly what how do I remedy this forklift
certification stream I get my forklift certification on
stream whoa wipe all the blood oh my gosh I can power wait I
don't need to be forklift certified I can power it with my
brain You literally said what I was thinking.
Kowalski.
Good thing I'm not colorblind.
I need to put these back.
Oh my gosh.
Every little duck in a row.
You haven't seen it yet.
You should take out Forklift Driver Klaus.
One of the best forklift related videos ever made.
I don't know it.
I would love to see it.
Okay, this isn't so bad.
Hopefully this is one of the more annoying areas, and we're
getting taken care of it.
Nice and quick.
So, we should be good.
Don't say anything if you know something, though.
Don't say anything if you're like, she doesn't know.
She doesn't know.
Forklift certified.
It won't move like this.
Yes, I'm working on it.
No, not the smileys.
You guys are scaring me.
Does she know?
She lacks information.
No!
Oh.
Kupansky, no!
Why am I...
You know, I understand.
I'm the crime scene cleaner.
But I think I'm the cleaner, not the picker-upper.
I feel like I'm...
You know, the children will never learn if you pick up their
toys for them.
That's what they say.
I don't know either.
We'll learn together.
Konof will learn together, okay?
You and me.
everybody else.
Luckily, these are not so bad to put away.
They're pretty generous, to be honest.
I would love if even... You love you even if you were a
bird.
And I'm definitely afraid of birds and people without
forklift certification.
I don't know how to tell you this.
Team Arno!
It's a bit early, but in my time zone, it's my birthday!
I wanted to say thank you, Mito, for always being a light in
my life for me and someone who brings me a fun time every
day we do love to you my new happy birthday happy happy
birthday happy birthday congratulations happy birthday with
salutations happy birthday may your sky stay blue
birthday to you.
We're so close in birthdays, guys.
My birthday is next week!
My birthday's next week!
I've got big plans, big plans, big cakes.
Not my own, unless.
Big plans, big plans!
be there be square only a little over a week but next week
wait a little bit over a week but next week next week next
week big cakes you say actually there are some need to clear
the way first there are some big cakes I'd say can I be a
oval yeah but as long as you still come to my birthday party
as long as you still go to my birthday party
wow okay this area is almost so clean isn't that crazy holy
cow pick me up human i will working on it this can go over
there and these all get picked up
We're missing one.
And we're missing a few things as well.
Money, money, money, money.
You had me at cake.
What kind of cake do you want?
I mean, I know it's my birthday, but I love you guys so
much.
I'll get the cakes that you want instead.
What cake do you desire?
Your cute little heart.
Panfetti.
Mint flavor?
Do they have a mint flavored cake?
I don't think so.
I think you made that up.
Oh.
Ow.
Ha!
Oh man.
Oh,
like a mint ice cream cake!
Oh, that could be good.
Wait, I think this is a secret.
Actually, I don't think it goes anywhere.
Never mind.
I lied.
Wait, we're missing a couple.
Where could they be?
We're missing one of these.
No, we're not.
Just kidding.
Okay, thank goodness, though.
Oh, we're missing...
Uh...
We're missing one of these...
And one blue tin.
One blue tub.
To be blue.
You could probably get away with cleaning a crime scene as
you're among the paranormal.
I mean, I don't want to brag, but I could get away with a
lot of stuff.
I could get away with a ton of stuff, probably.
Gamers never look up.
I did, I did!
I looked up.
And I saw nothing.
That's a pervert laugh.
Takes a pervert to know a pervert laugh.
Yeah.
Got you there.
Huh?
How do you feel about that?
Life is just more fun as a pervert.
And I think everybody can agree.
Honestly, we need more perverts making things.
Because gen- Ouch.
When someone is a genuine pervert and makes something, they
put such passion into it.
it you know the booze oh the boss wait wait hold on under
the the caption under my head says the boss but it
definitely says sign the booze the eye booze no fighting
container contents can go boom i can yell as much as i want
you can't good work equals good pay again keep your mouth
shut The disaster was waiting to happen.
Oh.
TV room.
Oh, lots of money.
So we will get a TV.
Is this not the TV room?
Is this like the break room?
Gosh, I would hit my head on that.
It definitely says booze.
Wait, what's this?
Huh.
Oh, we have to...
activate the elevator don't we we need that we need the pass
case or the pass card
but yeah definitely like you know perverts are the ones that
will make like a really good game because they care about
their uh their passions being represented you know what i
mean
I think I cleaned all these, so we'll do this.
We'll bring this down very carefully.
We'll put it here.
And we'll also bring...
Oh, dang it.
We'll refill this.
Particularly if it's rare.
Yeah!
If only we had more perverts making games nowadays!
That's what I'm saying.
Judgment day is coming soon.
Senron Kagura turns 15 today!
You're kidding.
That's crazy.
Senron Kagura is like a middle schooler now.
Wait, that's actually crazy.
It's that old.
the 15
is high school oh is it actually i have no idea oh wait is
this a oops i missed one well hoo-ha-hoo-ha this hoo-ha
hoo-ha hoo-ha and hoo-ha over here
i can't imagine how long some of these places would actually
take
American high school at least.
Wait, the middle school is what?
Like, 14?
You ever notice a beautiful art piece and notice the feet
are weirdly detailed?
That's pervert power.
The world needs more perverts.
It's just a genuine fact.
Oh, oops.
Oh no, I put the...
I put the...
I put the dirty in there.
Not bad.
Hopefully it's not too dirty, right?
right?
11 and 14.
Oh, I see, I see.
Oh, my gosh.
Wait, though.
Please, please.
Oh, no.
I think I got it stuck.
You guys, oh, no!
Hold on.
What do I do?
Katana?
Okay, I think it's budging.
I'm also pressing forward.
It's moving, it's working!
Just, I feel like...
Maybe, maybe this is fine.
Oh, please.
Oh my gosh, please.
Um...
I don't know.
Arrows.
Thank you so much for this over time.
Oh.
Oh no.
What do I do?
Oh.
I think she's got too fat an ass.
She got too fat an ass.
Ah!
We got it.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah!
Oh, dang, girl!
My butter to lobster or my steak to...
Juicy.
My bag too fat.
Alright, um...
I feel like we'll want the conveyor belt on just a little
bit more.
Oh, is this totally clean?
Just kidding.
Okay, let's take this upstairs.
yeah okay we have in here and probably people too so let's
go in here oh wait we couldn't go in here that's right oh
how do I get in okay hold on
there's a lot in there okay um is this door oh it's open
here now okay just kidding.
I was wondering if maybe the body here had blocked, like, I
made it so it wouldn't be possible to come back in here, but
it's the opposite.
What?
Let me in.
As Metal Gear Rising teaches, blade mode is the answer to
everything.
I know, I was a fool for doubting.
I was a fool for doubting.
Oh my gosh, this is so much trash and they're big pieces so
they'll all like this is gonna take like a million bags
combined it's okay we'll send everything down the conveyor
belt endless trash what the heck is it and
every box i'm gonna have to break every box you break every
oh what's this oh one more to the collection we got the
elevator every oh wait just kidding every trash you take
every oh Need to empty the trash can first.
Everybody you...
Uh...
Shake.
Every move you make, I'll be watching you.
Yeah.
Alright.
Well, we'll get cleaning in a second.
Let's put all these on the conveyor belt now.
How convenient?
I have another box, just kidding.
I think someone...
Oh, you just fell.
I knew it.
I'll be haunting you.
I have to break that one too.
Oh.
There we go.
Deploy.
Okay.
And you too, mister.
He probably died in an explosion along with all the
electricity.
Okay, see ya.
Oh, wait.
I gotta go get the stuff now, huh?
That's okay.
We have a shortcut.
Uh-oh.
You got this?
We seem to have run into a predicament.
Boy,
Sisyphus or something, right?
Come on.
No!
Oh, this is so...
Oh, he...
It's fine.
No!
It worked.
It was...
It's fine.
We're fine!
Excuse me.
Don't fall.
This feels like an OSHA violation.
Now what?
We give you that impression.
Get rid of the trash 90%.
What did I mean?
And I have to move.
two furnitures back to their place okay you come with me
first I hear them okay they're fine wait one is one one made
it the other is about to make it there we go I wish I could
find another place for to rinse my buckets it's gonna be
kind of tough I'm not gonna lie this room gonna be a little
tough.
Oh, oh, yes.
My knees of steel.
Get in there.
Yes.
Mundo, please don't haunt me, Minto!
Uh, you're gonna get haunted and you're gonna like it!
Oh, wait, hold on.
Wait, watch this.
But you, uh, away.
And then we'll bring him back out in there.
that room.
Haha.
Genius behavior.
You guys really want to get haunted?
You don't think it's like, you know, too spooky or anything
like that?
You think it's all...
You think it's all fun in games.
Now, don't you?
You're not taking it seriously.
You're not taking it very seriously, huh?
Oh my gosh, we're already dirty.
Ugh.
What was that?
I think this is not sudged, but that's okay.
Your bourbon is boring.
You say that.
You say, oh, please haunt me until your electricity bill
goes up because the lights have been flickering.
You say, wait a second.
Where'd my snacks go?
I'm having to buy double groceries.
What's going on here?
You say all that.
You say all this until...
And then you're like, get this, get this ghost out of here.
Babycore!
Thank you so much!
For the five, get did.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Ew.
Not the garbo oil.
Dang, those did good.
Do you pay rent if haunting us?
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
And then he asked, Did the ghost pay rent?
Yeah!
Think of it as A best friend you never knew you had and
never wanted.
You know?
Sometimes I think I'm not putting the suds on these things.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, no, it's already dirty.
At least fold my towels or something.
I may be a maid, but I'm a ghost first.
You want me to be your mom?
I am the victor.
Come on.
Yeah.
I resent that statement.
I'm taking this very seriously.
I found...
Oh, she complained!
Burned seeds.
Hey!
No, please!
It's so fun!
Just give me a chance!
Give me a chance!
Oh, gosh, you guys.
I fear we're about to...
Oh, my bad.
I'm starting to smell done.
One step closer to the foundation of a world.
I fear...
Oh, well, actually, I have a second button.
it right yeah it's still cleanish so maybe we'll be okay in
here maybe we'll be able to clear this room and go find
another place for to rinse our stuff I know no fear sage
makes me so sad I kind of like the smell of sage there are
many OSHAs but only one kami OSHA the OSHA to follow all of
all Osha's...
Oh, here, here.
Wait, did we get this room?
Oh, little stains?
I think?
Wait a second.
Oh, that's trash bags.
Ah!
Oh, no, no!
Weep all the blood!
Oh, it disappeared!
Let's go!
Okay, so we did get this area.
Yahoo!
Has this go showered already?
I do!
Every day!
Only sometimes every other day.
But mostly every day.
Mostly every day.
I promise.
What furniture do we need to put back?
I wonder.
You see that up there?
I have to get that.
Dude.
It says there's trash that we missed.
That didn't make a stain, did it?
No?
Okay, cool.
Oh, I see, I see.
Okay, I was...
I saw this earlier and thought that it needed to be put up.
But I didn't know where I...
And here.
Yay!
Johnny Churro funds.
Churro?
Johnny,
I don't think he can have a churros.
I don't think he would even like it.
He's gonna have a churro and break out into a fiesta.
Which would be kind of fun.
Oh, that's dirty.
I didn't know that would happen.
Oh, well.
It's fine.
Let's go take it around here.
Down here.
Oh, oh, oh, careful, careful.
Over here.
That's power.
How did I get up there before?
Oh, we'll do this part.
Oh, we found another one!
Yippee!
Okay, perfect.
Yeah!
I've made two to my brain.
Can I have the churro instead?
What about me, though?
Watch.
Wait a second.
I was adjusting in my chair and slipped.
I think I pulled something in my shoulder.
Oh, oh, yeah.
What are you?
It's not a churro, it's a churudu.
I'm not sure what it is exactly.
Oh, chudus make cats become like zombies.
They are obsessed with churu.
Cats love churu.
I think I'm okay.
I'm in a bit of pain.
But I'll be okay.
When the end of...
for Vinto, other end of, for Aibu.
We meet in the middle.
Like a lady in the trap moment.
But with a churro.
Sounds kind of good.
Yeah, it's like the tube tree.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Cats are...
They become actual zombies.
It's kind of frightening.
I'm not going to lie.
But they love it.
They absolutely...
Can I get in, please?
I can't I got in before hello Kovalski why can't you get in
now what's happening I get the same with a good cookie yeah
they'll like they'll like bite the tubes hello hey okay
there we go they'll bite the tubes they'll bite you they'll
bite Sorry.
Please don't kill me, Big Jim.
Please don't kill me.
They'll buy everything.
I was just about to switch to this guy, too.
They're fiends for Churu.
Be warned if you ever give your katachuru.
You must know what you are getting yourself into.
97% of blood.
Oh, I see.
Oh my gosh.
Dang it.
Okay.
Ha!
Yay!
Okay.
Um, where to next?
I want to try and find...
Oh wait, hold on.
Let me clean out my stuff first.
They have urinary safe chudu.
Well, I guess I'm going to have a couple of zombie cats now.
Wait, what do you mean urinary safe?
What does that mean?
I'm really glad my cat isn't a furniture and a destroyer.
I'm so happy for you.
Wait, this looks like a staircase, no?
This has to be.
Where does this go?
What?
Okay, I'm here.
Where are we going?
Stuff to steal.
Thank you very much.
Oh, it's just like a parkour way of getting up here.
Oh, that's right.
There was stuff over here.
Ah!
Oh.
Yoink.
They're like 90% water.
Oh yeah, oh to protect from kidney stones.
Yeah, but are regular tutors not urinary safe?
That's what I'm wondering though.
If you were the ghost haunting me, I would not exercise you.
You can eat my snacks and live and free in my house.
I wouldn't mind.
Really?
No take backsees.
That's not an evil laugh, by the way.
Just a regular evil laugh.
That's right, we had some bodies here.
How do I get up there, though?
Come here?
Facing the man above.
He must have been the one who shot him.
We can do this.
Watch.
Check this out.
Ah!
Aw, yeah!
I thought there would be a door here.
No!
Um...
Look at all this over here though.
How do I get there?
Maybe the elevator?
For now we'll just handle what we have here.
Oh wait, let's get this part.
Oh, I see an evidence too.
It's time for a perch.
Good throw.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Of course it's different when a ghost is eating your snacks.
It's just like...
I don't know.
It feels a little more innocent, doesn't it?
Oops.
Well, actually, we can do this.
Feels a little more innocent if a ghost is eating your
snacks.
Some people are less afraid of ghosts than they are of
humans.
Which kind of drives me crazy.
I'm like, come on guys, we gotta...
We gotta up our scare factor a little bit.
We can't let a stinking human be as...
scary as us?
Oh, hi Johnny.
Come here.
Welcome to my lap.
so there was the car in here you went in my lap come here
you can always eat my snacks I wish I had snacks right now
I'm kind of hungry
come into my lap Jonathan Jonathan please I think he's mad
at me because I'm not feeding him and he hasn't eaten in a
million years um okay well i guess we've done this area we
got that key card for the elevator so let's go check that
out i think that's i think we've done all that we can here
for now definitely finish this area so
Oh, oh, yeah, I'm bringing it here so that we can go through
the elevator.
Then I have to go back up.
La-de-do-de-do.
Oh.
Imagine if there was Abu named Jonathan watching right now.
There could never be.
Jonathan is, like, the most rare name you've ever heard.
I'm going to...
stop the...
What is... Oh, what is this actually?
My blue is...
Hatches.
Maybe we should keep that.
Purple for light.
So true.
I think Jehokushima made it up.
Right, exactly!
That's what I've been saying.
Oh, yellow for the crane.
stop stop oh he's just itching his okay hello oh my goodness
hi hello he's on top of me you want to do you want to sit
here you may i'm giving you permission hold on i gotta make
him comfy okay there we go yeah that's why they call you
john doe when he can't be identified it's so rare no one
could be named that see okay we will take out uh the
conveyor belt oh
oh yes
wait wait a second does this not go down does it only go up
wait i'm just gonna clean this real quick okay elevator
clean oh
here we go oh I just noticed it's clues about what happened
instead of evidence wait you're right I did notice that too
but then I was like oh has it always been you know guys I
don't know where my butt okay there's one bucket here and
one bucket here I lied I know where my buckets are we've got
our buckets yeah right Johnny Are you getting comfy?
Are you getting comfy, Mr. Mayans?
Yeah.
You're so silly.
Wait!
Okay.
Oh!
We got something else.
It was 100% evidence in the past levels.
Unless I'm being Mandela effect.
No, I agree.
I believe it was evidence in the last levels.
and then now it's clues for some reason.
To this...
basement?
What's here?
Where are we going?
Oh,
wait.
This is just where my truck is.
That and this.
We probably should, like, take out the boxes, huh?
Like, kind of our nuisance.
And you...
Oh, come on.
You!
Uh...
Johnny, I can't get it.
Um...
You!
Yes.
Very good.
Let's go.
Floor?
Where does floor one drop us off?
ah okay we're in here okay oh shoot there's this whole room
but there's no place to put the water now is there this
room's gonna be a pain in the butt wait this room's gonna be
such a pain in the butt the corpse wasn't the right shotgun
he's not allowed that's only right i drive you guys are
shotgun everyone else in the back everyone else squeezes in
the back little clown car will we ever get to see pictures
of johnny that aren't his chin what's wrong with his chin in
his mouth you guys don't like it but eventually probably
uh let's check out what is the um
let's check out what's on the second level maybe we'll do
that other area and we have to figure out how to get over
here as well
watch this oh my god
I did that I did that that was crazy oh it won I think this
is This is totally new territory.
What's this?
Ah, this is the...
A toy for big boys.
Why are you saying like that?
Okay, so that's how we get over there.
And, uh...
Wait, where did we come?
Oh, here.
I got you, sir.
Yeah, we haven't had any...
I haven't had any real, like...
music this level blackmail blackmail notes johan abrams drug
addict gambler lost his company in a bet wife and kids don't
know struggle with money johnny johnny johnny's a dropout
and has student loans oh no no no not the student loan
blackmail stress sick unpaid bills as well have a file that
says like my super evil plans how are there's wait Johnny
was the the janitor no there
a body in here or they just wreck the place and they have
they are listening to to classical music a hundred percent
serial like murderer that's just a classic trope
He's got double.
He's got double monitors though.
This one's not so bad then because there's no blood.
I'll put this for here right now.
Student loans, am I Johnny?
I don't know why the student loans are under the blackmail.
That's kind of messed up though.
Hi Johnny, welcome back.
tell me about your student loans you did not tell me about
this when i adopted you
are you hungry why are you bugging me what time is it it's
not close even to your dinner time it says collect evidence
here well i will steal their stuff that's what i'll do oh
there's another evidence right here i don't know how long
workers will manage without a raise they're pissed you can't
even pay rent when most of their payment is used to pay off
the debts they have ungrateful bastards if not for me they
will already be dead they aren't even in a position to
negotiate keep them on a tight leash look where that neglect
got you dang he
doesn't even have proper chairs for them
guys sit in the little plastic ones.
Has the radio heard the VODs at all, by the way?
It has not.
Thank goodness, right?
Alright, the office has been cleared.
Lovely.
Let's see.
I'll probably throw this that way.
It'll go somewhere.
Is there a place to...
Oh, yes.
Okay, good, good, good.
Oh, oh, no, no, no.
Wait, all my buckets are up there.
Wait a second.
We'll figure it out.
And a body.
And some more evidence.
Not the SMG.
Yeah, it'll go somewhere.
The body she threw earlier was stuck in the rafters,
imagine.
What do you think?
You think I'm so...
You think I'm...
So careless?
Never!
I'm whole in one Johnny!
I just discovered the name Johnny by the way.
Um...
Wait, do I have to get rid of these?
Maybe I do.
I'll just get rid of them anyway.
They all look damaged anyway, so...
Okay.
Oh, this one too.
Oh, yeah, this one too.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, and he has the thing for the lift.
Seems like they had it all perfectly planned.
Cool, John!
Motherfuckus, they chose death the moment they decided to go
against them.
Cool, John.
Boss, shall we bring anything today?
No, everything is on site.
John W.
Then we have John the Anyon.
What time do we start the party?
Can we start early?
You will hear the DJ.
Why is everybody this is...
Talked about how John was such a rare name.
And then literally everyone in this chapter is named John.
Stop it.
Stop.
Get off my chair.
Hold on.
He's being a little brat.
I'm going to go.
go give him.
I'm gonna go give him a little bit of food.
I'll be right back.
Not good.
Why are you all so happy?
Let's pick up this key.
Nope, not you.
Yeah.
Good, we can just start throwing everything here.
So, oh, okay.
Come on.
Pick up everything.
Welcome back, thank you.
Oh, no way.
I thought I cut it all.
Pick up everything.
Ha!
Because you're back!
Ah, I missed you guys too.
Oh, don't miss Johnny's stinking attitude, though.
He, like, liked these little treats.
It's not even a treat.
It's actually, like, a food.
Like, it's, like, dried, freeze-dried food or whatever.
He liked them when I first gave them to him.
And now, and I, and they're meant to be, like, a little
snack or, like, a topper to food or something.
And now...
guy out now he's being like so picky about it he's like oh
oh this this this stuff this is not what i requested i'm
like you quit bugging me the cat loves the free freeze dried
stuff yeah it's it's a good like little in-between like
dinner snack i just grab a handful and like put it in his
his bowl
Oh good, we can do the conveyor belt again.
Wait, I think we have two guys on the conveyor belt,
actually.
Oh, dang, I was so close.
Ooh.
Maybe if I throw it here.
Yeah.
Cat being a cat, I know.
Oh, no, buddy.
No.
Okay, watch this.
I still smell blood.
Oh, dang it.
Show hey, oh tiny over here.
I mean...
What can I say?
The ladies love a guy that can...
What is his thing?
Is he like a good pitcher or a badder or both or what?
My dog is exactly like that with treats.
She'll love the treat and then after enough time she'll
start complaining and even sometimes refusing to eat the
treats.
I mean, I know.
You know, I know that, like, I hate having the same thing
every day, but these are not even, like, an everyday thing.
It's just kind of, like, an in-between snap.
Thanks for the super chat, though.
Both.
Stop saying treat by chat.
My chat, my cat's going crazy.
Oops, sorry.
I won't say it again.
Treat.
evil way so that they don't get the right they think it's an
evil thing oh I didn't realize I thought it was just three
stuff three bags wait
how many bags can get can fit in here okay four bags good to
know
and keep going oh I am the
Alrighty, that should be all of that.
I believe I still don't know how to get up there, though.
Oh, we got another...
Mixed it.
Cheers!
I ne worth?
Woke?
I ne end?
Oh, oh, it says it up the- I was reading here.
It says it up there.
Let's put on some music, huh?
Let's put on some of the new music we got.
There's so many things I haven't found.
I think jazz has been really good lately.
Do we deserve a treat, please?
What kind of treat do you want?
I don't think this is jazz.
I don't...
I have a feeling this is not jazz.
Yoink.
I love this, this hot dog lunchbox, so...
Ha!
Nice.
Not nice.
That's okay.
I have a couple things I gotta clean up anyway.
Um...
Okay, thank goodness.
I was like, wait, that's a little high, no?
Can I lower it?
it okay there we go i'm sure they anticipated that happening
to other people
jazz could be everything if you wanted to i could i guess
you're right
careful careful
can i go down with this oh no no no no
This one's nice.
I like this one.
Actually, these are clean anyway, so I'll just take them.
No!
We lost it!
It's okay.
We can add more detergents.
I don't even remember what I did though.
I think the resistance one?
And then...
Cleaner one.
maybe strength don't remember okay
oh these are dirty I don't even realize
yeah yeah all right let's get mopping baby we'll do this no
time I think after this though Yeah, it doesn't seem like
we'll have So much left This area was big, but it wasn't so
Intimidating, luckily I think I think it was okay
What song is this?
Honestly, you can, I saw earlier today, you can get the Yeah
You can get the soundtrack for this game.
So, if you like the music in it, I would suggest the
soundtrack because you might get some of these songs too.
Yeah, yeah, the museum did have the glitch, right?
This one hasn't been so bad, but I feel like we haven't
gotten many secret areas at the same time.
So I'm wondering if I'm missing stuff, you know?
I only got... Oh, and there's also that one office that I
have to do that I have been avoiding.
That one will take a little bit of time because there's
no...
There's no buckets by it.
We gotta go up and clean our bucket.
Oh, never mind.
Cleaned itself?
Oh, no, it didn't.
I feel very serial killer.
How did I miss all these before?
Okay, okay, okay, okay, grab, grab them.
Nice.
Okay.
Clean, clean.
Scrub, scrub, scrub.
Is that everything in this area?
I know no fear.
Just a little bit of...
Oh!
Here, here.
Looks like somebody fell from there.
No, well let me get the roast.
All right.
Well, um, collect you.
Collect you.
Oh.
Oh, I probably should have cleaned my things first.
Hold on.
Whoops.
It's fine.
Oh.
Can you use anything as a stepping stool?
Oh, I guess you're right.
I think...
I wish I could power this.
Hoi!
He just won't lift!
My bad.
Let's go...
Back to the one's floor.
The...
Second, first...
First floor?
This one.
Watching biohazard bags fall a floor down is very cozy.
The little shh sound they make.
I get it, I get it.
Let's turn... Okay, let's add this.
Let's turn off... What happens if I turn off the lights?
Oh, okay, let's keep those on.
Okay, did not like that.
We'll turn off the hatches.
And we'll get those going again.
The conveyor belt.
We got many of bodies.
Whop.
Oh, come on.
I have to do everything around here.
I wonder if I could use, like, some of these boxes.
They won't let me pick them up, though.
Be nice if I could use them for getting up there.
I have to do everything around here!
We got a traffic jam.
There's one bozo.
Hey, come here.
Throw you there.
Pick you up.
You?
And another one?
Wait!
And so...
So does this count as maid duty?
It does!
How would it not?
I think it does!
Everybody agrees.
Everybody says it counts.
Did I get all of it?
Oh, oh, oh, guys.
Oh, okay!
Never mind!
We're not in trouble!
um this is the hatch oops I need to open the hatch I didn't
realize that was part of the hatch wait what's that oh yoink
hey oh I can make it
see I am still missing a guy there I haven't seen them Or
maybe I haven't been looking.
Hmm.
I'll have to go back around.
My bad.
Oh, cool.
Yeah, like a cat.
My instincts.
My reflexes.
Excuse me.
Oh, excuse me.
Let's turn off conveyor belt.
Open the house.
watches.
Do I have to do everything?
Do I have to do everything around here?
It's fine.
We'll just close it for now because we'll have more things
to do as well.
Okay.
I'm not looking forward to this room.
I... Yeah, there's a few...
furniture that we don't have not been able to put back in
its place human organs oh yoink tonight today's dinner is
canned sardine and canned tuna call big jib to hire another
cleaner see how that'll turn out are you threatening me or
keep your teeth clean what a great thing to say
Wait, we have some other songs that we haven't listened to.
Let's do this.
Yeah, yeah.
Minto in the house.
Here we go.
My name's Minky.
M to the I to the N to the K to the other I.
Yeah, I know how to spell.
Yeah, I went to school.
Because school is awesome and cool.
You gotta go there to learn some sick beats.
Drop it like me in 2020.
or maybe for you probably 2055 because you will be a adult
and then also you'll be able to rap just like me a big big
slap on the knee because it was a killer funny I'm so
awesome I got them rhymes and I also got all the time
because I'm dead and I've sickened the head I come up with
these beats on the fly because I'm fly and you can't rhyme
fly with fly but now I am.
I'm changing up the game and I'm bringing it here.
Oh yeah, oh yeah.
One day you'll catch these sick beats and you'll say, man I
wish she was haunting me in my house, eating my snacks,
bringing it down with these sick tracks.
Oh yeah, here I come.
clean in your whole place with her all the gum.
And that's my story.
I'm not sure how I die, but here I am.
And also, I like big fat booties.
And that is a really good thing.
Big booties will make the world peace.
So everybody should have big booty.
And then we'll have peace and it will be great.
Jiggle, jiggle, jiggle.
Wiggle, wiggle, wiggle.
That's what I'm gonna do to all them tittle.
Boodle, buddle, buddle.
Licious, licious, licious.
Yeah, baby, I can't get enough.
Oh, yeah.
M to the I to the N to the K to the other I.
I'm looking with my eyes at you with the big tush, the girl
over there.
Oh, yeah, she's so fine.
Oh, yeah, I'm gonna make her mine.
That mine is gonna be tush.
Just like the Kowalski banging on the trash can.
That's what I'm going to do to that, but...
How do you like my song?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, food not allowed for heating.
Tuna.
Eggs, herring, sardines, tuna, cabbage, soup, beans, cooked
cauliflower, broccoli, tuna.
fire.
I felt like I cooked a little bit until I you know started
talking about booty.
Yep.
Wait.
My stuff is clean.
I guess we could technically.
Hmm.
System is down.
The system.
That was the best part.
Okay.
Hmm.
I hope someone clipped that so it's immortalized I I'm the
best part is the stream's not going anywhere I
I turn this on no
I guess I could just jump from here that could work probably
a rifle Did you press the down button?
No.
Oh no, it's not cleaning up very well.
This was a mistake.
Hoo-ha, hoo-ha, hoo-ha, hoo-ha, hoo-ha.
Ooh, ooh, ooh, ooh.
Ooh, doo-doo-doo-doo-doo-doo.
Hoo-ha, hoo-ha, hoo-ha.
It's okay, we gotta get my stuff over there anyway.
Tried to send the peach emoji, but I guess it's bad.
Why is YouTube so...
YouTube, you're such a baby.
Ooh.
Wait, what's this?
We did get a room!
Wait.
Unknown keys.
We did get a key for the TV room.
I remember that.
What was that?
We'll have to find that note that said like the TV room,
whatever, whatever.
Whoa, look at all the guns in there!
Okay, hold on.
Let's figure this out.
We got a mystery key!
Pete!
It worked!
Let's do this.
Now I'm gonna collect it.
Oh, tip the bucket over 15 times.
I didn't!
The game is slandering me.
I feel like there's something behind here, no?
I feel like it in my bones that I don't have.
Okay, hold on.
Let's figure this out.
Let's get this up here real quick though.
Okay, very carefully.
That's fine.
How do I use this?
Oh, there we go!
Oh,
yeah!
I have to go do it again.
Careful.
What?
What is this?
Crime evidence.
Can I open this, though?
Hold on.
I will jump down to go in here.
Oh.
Okay, that's okay.
Okay.
We'll just lower it a little bit?
Or uh, raise it?
This is very fast for like machinery.
Oh, what's in here?
Oh my god, the cons- that's a big jib!
I wonder if he told anybody about it.
If he had, I would have known about it.
Cousins.
Thank you.
Your peach didn't show up.
Where are the bodies responsible for?
The Italian mob.
Big Jim.
Oh, it's so funny.
There no more evidence here?
That's it?
Okay, I have almost all the evidences.
I need one more.
And we have I can't tell if the bodies...
Nice.
I can't tell if the bodies are haven't, like, if I haven't
gotten all of them or some of them haven't made it into the
the truck, the back of the truck.
It's time for a We'll grab the trash while it cleans the...
We got rid of all the trash!
Yay!
Luckily,
these are already sudged.
Suds de dubs.
Suds and suds.
Nice, nice, nice.
Ah, yeah.
Here we go.
Yeah, we got all the blood in the container lot at least.
Wait, so we're missing an evidence.
Maybe in there?
I don't think so.
Ha!
Oh, I missed it again.
Okay, hold on.
We'll,
uh...
Let's work on this guy real quick.
Hang ya!
Let's lower it a little bit.
Holy!
Alright, that should be good.
Oh!
Careful.
I forgot my guy!
Uh-oh.
Okay, nice.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Now I'm
that arrogant piece of trash promoted me, so you must trust
me on some level.
He's weak now, and won't see what's coming.
Says John.
Big Jim.
You will pay for what you to my daughter.
Their leader wanted revenge for murdering his daughter.
You need yourself some enemies.
The higher person treated him well.
And look what's happening.
Because they'll look at it by so.
We'll do.
Wait, what do you mean evidence in the office?
I picked up everything.
Uh-oh.
Unless he means like...
Wait.
Oh?
Wait, I left...
Oh.
Tammy was the girl killed in the pizza job.
Oh, I see, I see.
I was wondering.
All right, so let's open the hatch.
Can I?
Can that move any?
No.
What opens this door?
Right.
But we still have mysteries.
We're not quite done yet.
Oh.
Uh.
Oh, oops.
Yay!
What happens if I keep it on?
If I keep everything on?
Is it just gonna explode?
Alright, let's get this guy in here.
I'm starting snow extermination.
I think you have to parkour for that door.
I was trying to see if like...
If we can move this anymore, but it doesn't seem like it.
Hmm.
This song sounds almost like 007.
Do you guys hear it?
Yeah, there's a couple trashes that I gotta grab.
And a couple bodies.
So let's see what it says after we throw everything in here.
You do now?
Yeah, right?
Okay.
All right.
This should be the last one.
Yahoo!
Except it says we're missing a garbage bag.
Where?
Oh, up there.
Okay.
Oh, I forgot to put the...
No, I did put the power back on.
Thank goodness.
Let's go.
to floor zero?
See?
How European of them calling it zero.
Over there?
Oh, maybe.
And I'm still missing some stuff here.
Hmm.
Come on.
Jumping.
Please.
What the heck?
He keeps jumping and pushing himself off.
Crouch jump.
There we go.
Yoink.
It's just those two things.
One box is on top of the light.
In the box area.
Oh my gosh.
You're still...
Oh yeah, we totally found that.
Oh my gosh, how did you see that?
It wasn't lighting up.
Unless it was.
What?
That's great.
That is pretty mean, huh?
So the other thing in the trash maybe is...
Okay, it's in there.
Got it.
I saw it due to seeing several people play, but I appreciate
you.
Oh, helping me as well.
Thank you.
There's no way I would have ever spotted that.
That's craziness.
Wait, watch this.
Colby.
Oh, so close.
It's true gamers don't look up.
Oh my gosh, it wants me to rearrange these.
I don't even notice that.
Oh my gosh.
We would have been not 100%ing this, you guys, if I didn't
double check these.
Oh.
And...
Ah!
We used the unknown key!
Celestial Empire.
Yoink, yoink, yoink.
Oh, don't break.
Yoink, yoink, yoink, yoink, yoink, yoink.
Come on, let me take him.
I'm going to be so cursed by the end of this.
Awesome.
I'm going to have curse of raw, curse of...
Curse of...
This is...
King Tut.
curse of everybody all right so we use that key i feel good
about that
oh another thing to take so many things get like hidden you
know behind areas oh i think i have to
oh my gosh how do i get up into there i think that's where i
have to get and to go into there How?
Curse of everything.
Curse of raw, curse of mule, curse of me.
I'll be so cursed, it'll be cursed by association.
Oh, the step ladder!
I forgot it!
Wait, do I have one?
I don't have one.
No, I don't have a step ladder!
Wait.
Can I use this chair?
Come on.
No!
Uh.
Check it.
Oh, I'm so close.
I need free skill points to unlock it.
Oh, you're...
I mean...
I guess we could, but I don't want to spend that.
Oh, actually, I do.
Wait, what's an under now?
Tibles?
There we go.
yeah find zach's secret room who's zach wait what was that
oh oh there's this thing too what is this due to a device
malfunction please do not use more than three panel panels
simultaneously if more than three panels are used the entire
system will shut down within seconds and will be need to
restored from downstairs oh then it's a good thing we have
scheduled an electrician to fix the issue and he will be he
will come tomorrow and a few days soon okay zach oh zach you
hide potato chips and sardines and you're something crime
scene cleaner
who is zach
Who is Zack?
Is that Zack?
She's gonna leave that one blue canister out of place.
I won't!
I've been trying to find it!
What is that?
What's in there?
Oh, bring your findings into the office.
Oh, that's what that's what that's what it is.
okay and
we have this whole room to clean still have all this to do
we're busy we're busy i should probably just get on it
though so that i stop procrastinating and just do it i'm
just not looking forward to having to take all my stuff you
know like i'm gonna have to take all my buckets around and
everything you know not looking forward to that Hmm.
Put you up.
Mm-hmm.
Like, where is York's secret room?
It's so true!
York doesn't have a secret room because he's, you know...
York is out in the open.
Zach is the only...
They're not even clean.
What if?
We utilize all of our...
We utilize everything.
So before we have to...
Before we have to go...
Uh...
Re-clean.
Or re- like...
Yeah.
Come on.
Yes.
This is good.
Too far.
Okay, my bad.
too far.
There we go.
Something is blocking the way.
Nice.
Okay, this isn't so bad.
York abandoned his secret room ages ago because he went
coffee.
I get it.
Anything in here?
Oh, we can't open it.
That sucks.
Are they still dirty?
No.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's go back to some of our other songs on the soundtrack.
Oh wait, what's this one?
Oh, my hand.
Uh, well.
Let's go back down, I guess.
Where are my buckets anyway?
Do I have them all in my hand?
Oh, I do.
The thing is, this is the thing.
I'm gonna have to either leave them somewhere.
What the?
That's not where my bucket is.
I'm either gonna have to leave them somewhere or like
Carefully bring them back up here Dancing mint kawaii
Unless I don't
think we need Hatch anymore.
We're not right now
It uh-oh
Then we can run over there.
We gotta also bring our stuff here anyway.
We wanted to see.
They got a lot of dirt on you, didn't they?
The truth is, everyone really wants a piece of fiction for
themselves.
Sweeping everything under the rug can only get you so far.
Jimmy Look who's talking.
Oh, believe me, I can get me quite far So, I guess it's not
your first time You see, once you know when the place
becomes too hot In this right here, it's scorching That's
when you move somewhere else Maybe it's time for a little
vacation Now, to hope that he actually means
Huh.
Oh wait, that's right.
Is it working?
Can't see.
I don't think it picked it up.
They can't.
I'm getting a bad feeling.
Me too.
Alright.
So we'll use this one after all for our buckets.
Or for like re- for cleaning them and all.
You're so invested in this.
Me too.
Game is so good.
Alright, so we gotta clean this room.
And then we gotta find that last hole.
And then we'll be good.
And we can skedaddle.
Oh, I forgot.
Let's go grab.
This will be our suds bucket.
It's only a little inconvenient.
to run to this one, but it's much better than the
alternative, I'd say.
This game is so good.
I know I have like the Halloween maps as well.
I guess Halloween maps is what you'd call them.
But it's just so fun.
I'll be sad when we finish like the story even, you know?
I think it was Resistance.
I can't remember.
It's fine.
We're in the last bit.
Here, we'll just do this for now.
It is very engaging.
Oh, and my sponges.
There you go.
I've heard, though, that the bonus maps are, like, actually
quite different.
So they're, like, similar.
Oh, geez, it got dirty so quite fast.
They're the same maps, but also not really.
intrigued what that could mean.
Yeah, the voice acting in this game is good.
Everything's so fun.
I'm such a big fan of this game.
I feel like more people...
If you like Power Wash Simulator, I feel like way more
people could pick up this game.
Because it's got like the cozy aspect of Power Wash, but...
You know, if you like a little bit of creepy atmosphere, In
that regard, too.
You?
There we go.
I'm such a big fan.
Was that everything?
Wait.
Did we get everything in here?
Move the furniture back to its place.
What are we... What's missing over here?
We're missing a couple things, apparently.
I know, no fair.
but they're not showing up
oh this got knocked over my bad the paper cups on the floor
I know right wait move furniture 15 out of ah okay that goes
up there oh this goes back there oh yippee okay and then I
wish there was like a
all like a hundred percent meter you know what i mean like
we come out here it says everything's completed but we know
we're missing that one piece that one thing we're
missing this i'm looking i'm searching with all my eyes and
all my might i really can't see it the one piece and then we
have this this guy which I close the hatch we'll just run
this down real quick
I passed it I did oops
but because I have to to make sure like I think that I 100%
did it you know I feel like I have to go through every
single room and it's kind of a pain in the butt to check
them off.
Hiding in plain sight.
It is!
It's not in the ceiling, is it?
Huh?
Take a good look at those canisters.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
No way.
Okay.
Thank you guys.
No!
It escaped my sight.
I think all of everything here is good as well.
Just double checking.
Okay, power supply.
It says we're fine.
There was one.
That's crazy.
That's sneaky.
There was a thing to grab up.
here as well like a thing I could steal there there there
nice I think we're just gonna call it and say that we got
everything did you find the TV room no you're right you're
right you're right it said unless this was no no we saw the
thing about the TV room upstairs Secret in the container
area.
No.
By the power supply.
It said it was by power supply.
Is that what it said here?
I'm just double checking the...
It was in here.
We gather by the old TV room above the power supply.
Wait.
Above the power supply.
We did find that one room...
in power supply?
I think actually we did find it.
No?
I think we did.
Because... No, I think I did.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I did because...
I went through the vent.
And it took us above...
Power supply, no?
No.
Different?
Ah!
Oh.
Oh, it was a mistake.
Ah!
find all music cassettes wait but what are these then mr
president these guys scared me miss the box stairs secret
too just didn't turn around wait really box stairs wait what
is that there were so many box stairs that i've done i have
no idea which one you're talking about
Cardboard backroom vibe.
This one?
You have to go higher.
Can we get my tire?
Over here.
Ah!
Dark illusions.
Yeah!
Okay, I think I did...
I think that's it, then, right?
I think that's it.
Thank you so much.
I think we're good then.
Now I think we're good.
That's everything.
Thank you guys for helping me out.
Get everything.
Let's go home.
It almost feels like there should be something over here,
no?
Oh!
Well, a little bit.
Hi!
Hell...
Well...
Alright.
That's the name of the game.
Perfect score, perfect score, perfect score!
Title drop.
He knew he was title dropping too.
That one took two hours.
Craziness.
Almost $30,000.
Congrats on beating Act 1.
I hope to see you do Act 2 in the future as well.
Lots of love from Finland, Minto.
Captain, thank you!
Uh, uh...
Muay!
Thank you, thank you.
And?
All the secrets?
Yeah!
What's that, it?
That was Act 1.
National White Chocolate Day, yum.
Have you guys seen that bird that, like, his owner does
death metal?
And, like, you know, like screams and everything.
And so he'll try to scream too, and he'll go, Blum, blum,
blum!
That's how I feel when I, that's what this song makes me
want to say.
You gotta find that.
It's so funny.
It's so awesome.
The music in this game is crazy though.
Yay!
Look at- oh, we just saw that card.
It took me three months to stop vocal stimming, glass.
You can't do that.
Glass.
I always say shrock.
I'll never escape Glassk.
Metal.
I say metal.
Glassk.
Shrug.
I'll never escape Glassk.
It's too good.
Why would you want to escape?
Yay!
This game is so awesome!
Good job team!
Playful cat spirit!
Oh my gosh!
Davy!
You did great job!
I don't know how to pronounce any of these names.
Oh my gosh.
Marcy!
Oh, great job everybody!
Great job!
Everyone was so amazing in this game.
Well now I'm wondering how long is Act 2?
And then for the nightmare levels are they all is it every
single level now you have to become the truest of maids the
criminally cute guy and glad you enjoyed this game it was
really cool Argent Eon thank you thank you special thanks to
you the player and you the watcher a bit shorter there's a
few other levels as well every act one level has a nightmare
level that's crazy wait that's actually crazy hi johnny come
here oh you're yawning you're tired oh there goes the music
much to be cleaned do we escape like big jim's clutches good
evening i guess not right notorious gangster big Jim real
name James O'Connor was arrested last night after a
high-speed chase for reckless drunk driving authorities have
long suspected whoa what's going on in that car operations
from his warehouses and being involved in multiple murders
but he has evaded justice for years due to lack of evidence
oh I wonder why who believe this could be a major
breakthrough in their fight against organized That's not a
big jam!
Wait.
That's the wrong guy!
Unless he lost a lot of weight.
I'm home.
Accept mission from your computer, go to bed, go to the car.
Why do I have everything to do?
Wow, our house is so nice now.
and everything.
What?
What, Johnny?
That was a medium, Jim.
You're right.
Come here.
Come here, baby.
You're such a big baby.
Hold on, I'm gonna let you guys hear.
Hello.
Do you want to say anything?
Are you shy?
I He's got a little meows.
Oh, my goodness.
Yeah.
What?
Oh, sorry.
Why?
He's such a complainer.
No, that is not Big Jim.
Hey.
Oh, he's yawning.
He's yawning again.
Okay, bye-bye, bye-bye.
He wants to be fed, or he wants attention, or he wants
something.
Where's my daughter?
Is she not?
Oh, he's back again.
What do you want from me?
I think he wants to be held like a baby.
I want to be held like a baby.
You.
Do you ever open the lockers in the basement of our house?
pretty sure you want to be held like a baby what do you want
you're distracting me you're being so cute this is my cat
he's very clingy let's go check the basement oh all of our
things what did we take from the warehouse i guess nothing
it doesn't seem like maybe was that painting always no that
was from what was the painting always there i don't think so
who were we playing with one of the ghosts perhaps I got dog
food and a
rake oh because our tapes used to be out here and now oh
this is a new wall
Miss Clayne and Mr. Power.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, we can get more.
Whoa, laser washer.
Holy water into cleansing wine.
I need her.
Suspicious bookshelf.
This one?
Yeah, right?
Very, very suspicious.
My katana!
We can also make it into an electric guitar.
And we can upgrade our... We can change our... We can do a
pizza truck!
Winter camel!
What the heck?
Maha truck.
Tokusatsu!
We have to have the Tokusatsu glove.
Oh.
It's cleaning time!
Which one?
Which one do you guys want?
We don't have green, sadly.
We could do pink.
But red, we'd be the main character.
Pink or run?
Oh, we have 15 points.
We could, like, do more of our skill tree.
I don't think there's much left, honestly, but...
We could do more of the pressure washer.
Maybe carry an additional mop, huh?
Or actually, we'll do this one.
And mop and they...
We can no longer leave stains.
Oh,
wait.
Oh, shoot.
I didn't.
Oh, I'm silly.
There we go.
And we have all of these.
I don't need the...
We have everything here.
I don't...
I never really used the lamps or anything, so I'm okay with
that.
Uh...
Yeah, additional UV.
We're okay.
Wow, this is awesome!
Wait, I want to get a new...
What?
I tried it!
That's crazy.
Go, go, power!
Minky!
I mean, we have points, why not, right?
Wait, can we... Oh, only new colors.
Let's do it!
Millennial green.
It looks a little...
mintish.
stop stop stop stop stop please stop stop police voice oh
sorry police violence no we'll go with this one yeah
pressure washer my katana
police sirens i want the why is his name john johnny this
whole game is about you this whole game is full of johns and
johnny's how do you How do you feel about that?
How do you feel about that?
You missed the cat eyes and the other.
But I don't have it.
I can't.
I have to finish.
I don't have it unlocked.
Your mobile grandpa.
Wait, I want grandpa.
Wait, are you okay?
What's wrong?
He's like kind of freaking out.
I'm gonna go check.
Wait, what time is it?
It's not even... You have an hour.
Why are you freaking out?
Are you okay?
What's wrong?
What's wrong with you?
He's being weird.
Mad scientist.
Wait, it does kind of look like Rick, no?
From Rick and Morty?
That's kind of goofy.
Oh, magician.
Wait, I want the black hole.
The suitcase is great.
Portable shredder.
If only it actually shredded them, no?
Hmm.
Oh, that's...
Let's do the water pistols.
Those are fun.
Instead of the scrubs.
You could do the bunny.
That's funny too.
Hmm.
So, if I look...
Game development hell.
Holy big location.
We are the community.
We have been selected to work for us, Mr. Kovalski.
We believed the heart at Wild CEO when he said his team was
going to create the perfect game.
entertainment product of all time sadly the so-called life
simulator project failed to meet our expectations it didn't
even reach the beta stage we had to opt for the ultimate
restructuring also known as the purge oh now you the best
cleaner in your area have the honor of tidying up this place
we are the community if you are not with us we'll make you
regret you were conceived community again we are We
transformed the world from behind the scenes.
We've had our eyes on you for a while, Mr. Kovalsky.
Your work was impeccable, so we're giving you a task of
cleaning up one of our facilities.
We have had a serious breach of protocol, which resulted in
death and chaos.
Do your best.
Be diligent and discreet.
Everything you witness can be used against you.
We are the community.
If you are not with us, your days are numbered.
They do drive a hard bargain, huh?
Um.
They did also say that I could go to sleep.
So what happens if I go to sleep?
I wonder.
They can't spell.
Memories?
It's hard to believe she's finally coming back.
After everything we've been through.
My name's John Kovalski.
Treatment status completed!
Okay, well soon, Elena.
We're praying for you every day.
Everyone in the class is missing you so much!
Greg.
You know that guy's a troublemaker.
You know Greg is a troublemaker.
Oh, Elena, that's her name.
More evidence.
What's the other evidence?
This guy.
Oh yeah.
You can see my tokusatsu.
No.
Oh my god.
I'll clean up tomorrow.
Wait.
What are we getting ourselves into, you guys?
What are we getting ourselves into right now?
It's hell, it is hell.
Oh, this is great.
I wonder if it's not as efficient, though.
What's in here?
Oh, it's hell.
Reserved!
Touch the boat.
What does that mean?
What did they do to this place?
The soap is in there.
These children have no manners.
It's this music again too.
Wait, do I even have, yeah, I have my, I have my eyes in it
and everything.
This is so weird.
We're cleaning up actual messes and not, not blood.
We're cleaning up actual messes.
We're doing an actual janitor job.
Remember to flush!
I got an achievement for flushing.
You guys remember to flush, right?
Of course you do.
Doing his actual day job.
Yep.
Oh, we have to clean up the graffiti too.
Oh my goodness.
Work, work, work.
That's what I'm doing.
This is hell.
Why am I back here?
Maybe he likes this more, though.
But the money, Kovalsky, think of the money.
I'm just trashing this kid's notes.
That's so rude.
My ultimate blacklist.
Father, don't call me dad, you little sheesh.
Principal Anderson.
Do we have a problem, Mr. McCormick?
Entire basketball team, except Earl.
All the girls in my class, except Nadine and Maybe, and Big
Maybe, Carla.
My definitive whitelist.
Mom, my best friend, Eric.
Our biology teacher, Miss Pessel?
She gave me an A.
Our janitor, Mr. Kovalski, just...
a cool adult which isn't that often yay i guess i don't
suspect okay good we don't have to do these mess will always
be somewhere bless this mess they say until they have to
clean up the mesh they say bless this mess because they
don't have to clean it up After all the things I had to do
for Big Jim.
Jim, Jim.
Nice.
After all the things I had to do for Jim, Jim, Jim.
It's the pink Ranger suit.
Yeah.
Yeah, they think it's the coolest ever.
Oh, there's more trash here, huh?
That should be all of it.
No?
Oh, just kidding.
What am I missing?
What?
Oh.
Is that...
What am I missing?
Weird.
Unless it's like in here or something.
No?
The shoe and the toilet?
If it didn't light up...
No, I can't even grab it.
Oh, I see it.
A cigarette?
How dare?
Do these need to go anywhere?
I guess not.
These children are naughty!
These children are so naughty.
Okay.
Come here.
Come here then.
Yeah, we'll do the second bucket thing.
that big of an area but how do we get to the nightmare or i
guess this is the nightmare huh i think we're in the
nightmare this is the nightmare the tp is furniture oh it is
okay i was wondering
oh i'm starting to appreciate the moment when i was shut up
let's see I was wondering where it went though didn't seem
to really go anywhere we'll figure it out yes Johnny have
you seen my ducky the best high school football player is
looking for a date for prom if you're a beautiful girl who
would like who would look great with a handsome guy get in
touch.
Chad Handsome Johnson.
Quiz Lovers Club.
Gamdle.
Scrundle.
Whoa!
Time guesser!
Baindle!
Oh, yeah.
Isn't this like an elementary school?
Where do these go?
Oh, here they go.
Oh, I see.
Oops.
And,
uh...
Wasn't there a perk that allowed you...
Oh, that allowed you to see furniture that was not
properly...
Hold on.
Am I... I'm not crazy, right?
Oh no!
I sent pieces of missing furniture!
Oh...
Yeah.
I did the infinite cooldown.
I think the furniture one would have been...
Much more...
Yeah, I think...
I think it's more worth it now.
This probably goes somewhere, no?
Oh, there, yeah.
They wouldn't let me swap now, but I think we can
eventually.
Important questions, toilet paper, over or under?
Over.
Never under.
Always over.
Working for a mob was a wild ride.
Now, Big Gem went completely off grid.
I'm back to where I started.
What happened here?
Oh, my goodness.
A party.
Crazy party.
Is this a...
Is this a kid's party?
Oh, my God.
What happened here?
My goodness.
I kind of miss the crime scenes.
I'm not going to lie.
I do like this part.
But I miss the crime scenes.
Ooh, creepy.
Shut that.
They broke vases.
They broke everything.
Get that pizza.
Oh my gosh, everything up here too.
Single pizza slice.
We're just going to throw away all this good pizza.
Oh my god, these kids are naughty!
Sweet 16!
Oh, Greg is still there.
What can I say?
We got more stuff.
Down
here.
Aww, Dexter!
What do I need?
Oh, more trash.
Not the...
Oh, I thought it was evidence.
Elena.
Oh, we
need...
Elena!
Dexter's also getting old.
What else we got?
Furniture back to where it needs to go.
So this too?
Oh.
Yeah.
And this probably, yeah.
What is this?
I have one more chair.
I just don't know where it is.
Oh, here it is.
Is it the fan?
Oh, wrong.
Oh my gosh.
That's funny.
Yeah.
Where's the exit?
We came in through this one, so I guess we leave this way.
Elena is basically a grown-up at this point.
It's not easy.
But I guess I must learn to live with that.
No!
Please!
This is actual hell!
You guys didn't tell me the...
You guys didn't tell me the nightmare!
Oh my god!
The nightmare areas are a true nightmare!
What is this?
Hold on.
I'm gonna go check on...
Johnny, okay.
I like that.
I don't know.
He's got a toy that, like, makes noise.
And I thought he was...
I thought he was making noise.
Making...
Get into trouble, you know?
If these kids knew...
I want to go back to primary school.
Brother, you're in...
You're...
You're only...
We're throwing away the spoon you're only in high school
Wait until you're out in the world
Yeah, what is this?
Maybe that one community company.
Hello?
What?
Donnie you're being a little you're being a little stinky
Maybe it's a little stinky because you're cute.
Won't you bother me?
Would have... Yeah, they would have been allowed to nap
again.
One time in my school when it was nap time, my grandpa came
to pick me up.
The grandpa that was married to my grandma, by the way.
My infamous grandma.
He came to pick us up or pick me up.
But he wore this like devil mask that we had for Halloween
so we like bust through the doors and he's like and
everybody screamed everybody was really kind of traumatized
I didn't like nap time after that Oh, did we get raided?
We're crime scene cleaning, but we're not doing a crime
scene at the moment.
So I guess I know, you know, it was good.
It was good while it lasted, but...
Well, I could nap.
Spank, thanks so much for the five.
Get there.
Thank you.
Adargo, thank you so much for the gift.
Fix this.
Everything is disgusting here.
I hear like a static.
Coming from over here.
You guys hear it?
Kind of freaky.
There's so many trays.
Is this...
It's kind of a crime.
See, vandalism is a crime.
You know what?
You're right.
You're so right.
You...
You're right.
Vandalism is a crime!
If I bring my Ausinator out here...
Refreshing the air.
But I leave him in this world, will he come back to me?
My big question.
If I'm using water guns, how are they gonna get...
dirty?
Cleaning is my passion.
Yeah, I guess I ran out of water, but...
I ran out of water.
I guess so.
There we go.
Yes.
Yes!
And...
I think?
That one looks like a ghost, doesn't it?
Very spooky.
What is this substance?
I'm concerned.
The kids are maybe not okay.
Oh my gosh.
More trash.
Oh yeah, I forgot.
I was like, what do you mean only 82% of trash?
I forgot we have the whole other room.
Oh.
yes yes oh cleaning is my passion very
good very very good just a little bit of ectoplasm this
place is actually haunted oh this is clean wait clean one
could say the kids aren't all right they're not these kids
ain't right I know aren't the pink power power I almost had
power puff pink power Ranger gloves so cute aren't they so
cute what am I hearing the static still doing this Elena's
going away to college soon I'll be all alone with this
pathetic excuse for a job no this is a respectable job
please Kovowski Being a janitor is a great job.
It's a respectable job.
Oh, I forgot to do my whatever.
Actually, I'm just...
No!
Oh, was I supposed to...
Was I supposed to trash these?
Oh, I guess I could if I felt like it.
Does this go up here?
Move forward.
furniture back to its place.
Uh-huh.
Respectable.
Yes, great.
No, okay.
I guess that's true.
Wait, where'd my...
Where'd my other bucket go?
Did I bring it in there?
Oh, I just threw them out!
Hot go.
on the rack okay i am curious where this will go you know
and by this i mean like the uh the story of this part okay
i've i've always been so gentle
other bucket was over there too was it there's nothing to do
here oh i see Thank you.
Too eager to clean.
I'm amazed.
It's in my...
It's in my DNA.
You know?
I gotta clean.
See, I told you he's yearning for the crime scenes.
Oh, come on.
I bet though, like when you don't have to work with a bunch
of people.
It's kind of nice, you know?
Yeah.
It's probably nice when it's just like, oh yeah, I just show
up at the scene of the crime.
And there's another evidence.
I don't have to think about anything.
Anyone?
I can't move up to 99%.
I just do it.
Wait, how do I, there you go.
Where's the rest of the patch?
Working in solitude.
It is a wonderful thing.
Does that need to go back?
No?
Just getting into the zone?
Yeah!
So nice.
Oh my gosh, I need that.
Let me switch please!
I don't know where these dang things go.
No, it won't let me switch.
Can't switch skills during a mission.
But it's never ending.
Please!
Pan is on the stove?
Oh, I see it.
Thank you.
But there's still two things left.
to go somewhere?
Does that go back?
No.
Oh, yes, I think they do actually go up here.
Maybe?
No?
Okay.
The tables, are they not?
Oh!
The trays!
These!
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Banana.
My evidence.
Starlight, Starbright, Saturday Night, Dance.
Can't hide our pride.
I didn't go to my prom.
There's nothing to do here.
Because I had no one to go with.
But also, I regretted not going because they had a chocolate
fountain.
Then...
I don't think the banana is the evidence.
I thought about maybe the coloring book, but it's not it
either.
I went with my best friend.
We just hung out.
I didn't have really many friends either.
At school, at least.
And so, the one friend I did have, she was like half Normie,
you know?
So, she...
went with the intention of hanging out with them.
You know?
I have no idea.
Is it you?
What could it be?
What could the evidence be?
Read you be gone.
You were pronging!
Oh my gosh!
Oh wait, what is this?
Oh, here we go.
Amber alert.
Dang.
We scruindle.
I think we should probably...
Last seen in Quiet Hill State Park, approximately 6.30 p.m.
She's the same age as Elena.
I hope they find her soon.
One!
More Raiders!
Thank you!
Welcome, welcome!
I'm gonna experiment.
Do my buckets...
Stay?
Here's one.
Let's see.
Next up, home sweet home.
Would you?
Thank you.
So, today is the day.
Dexter!
Ready?
I look like I'm cosplaying.
I'm coming from a anime convention.
I still have more work to do.
What's her room look like now?
Whoa!
Oh, some of these places...
That's not the pool we cleaned up, is it?
That's not that pool we cleaned up, is it?
I sure hope not.
This is so sad!
We're watching!
Oh!
What, Johnny?
What, what, what?
my god she's leaving oh look that looks like my triangle all
the tissues i don't think they're tissues i think she i
think they're like uh put elena's luggage onto the truck's
bed no this is so sad seems like just yesterday she was
listening to my bedtime stories and now she's an independent
woman
photo with paul oh yeah these are all things we've looked
at.
I'm being very gentle with them, Elena.
Don't worry.
Dexter!
What a good boy.
He's been through it all.
Is this one?
She didn't take much with her.
not too independent if she needs her dad yeah right we're
missing two more things okay Dexter come on oh come on
Dexter you're getting in the truck oh here's oh here they
are not the song being like goodbye yeah goodbye Elena if
you had a daughter named Elena and she's leaving for college
this song is for you goodbye yeah oh oh are you sure you
want to proceed you will not be able to continue cleaning
further yes
Did somebody get her?
At all the color, did you notice the place turned like black
and white too?
It was losing all the color while we were cleaning.
What, Danny?
I made nobody!
Wait, but I worked at school!
That's my actual job!
And they don't even pay me?
Stop it.
You have to be patient.
You have, you get fed in 45 minutes.
Stop it.
They paid you an experience.
You're right.
I'm non.
Hi, Mr. Kovalski.
It's Zamburg, Big Jim's daughter.
No.
Did you miss me?
I know you and Elena are doing great, but if you want your
carefree living to last, you have to clean something for me.
Stop it.
I pay better than my old man.
no worries but if you fail me it's a sick world out there
who knows what could happen to your daughter so here it is a
wake-up call I never ordered I really believed it was all
behind me I can't hold you Johnny I have to play the game I
can't hold you in my arms stop climbing climbing me.
He's being very persistent.
Just like her dad.
She didn't learn nothing.
Oh, wow.
Fancy.
Oh, that's what she took a photo of.
We got her own pool.
Oh.
Johnny.
Johnny, please.
Oh, my gosh.
He's like climbing onto my shoulder.
Okay, we'll take a second to hold the baby.
Are you okay?
Are you okay, baby?
Do you need to be held like a little baby?
Do you need to be held like a baby?
Nope, he wants food.
He's begging.
You're being a begging cat.
Why are you doing that?
Why are you so...
Oh, my goodness.
Sorry, guys.
He's being so persistent.
This is like...
It's nice.
Don't get me wrong.
It's just very small.
You know, like...
You can't do laps or anything around this.
Okay, he's being so insistent.
He says... Wait.
Oh, we do still have our old layer.
Whoa!
Super stalker!
Ha!
Oh, shoot.
Johnny stop profit margin rising oh shoot Johnny stop my
profits
some of these some of these look like they would be perfect
but they're not.
Stop biting me!
You're being naughty!
Oh!
No!
I can't see!
Okay, so it gets fatter the more perfects you do.
I see.
Why is it so easy to do the skinny ones is perfect?
Oh no.
No!
Middle class wannabe!
I didn't even make it to six figures, you guys.
No!
This is so funny.
Wake up, America.
She's like literally taking a nap.
Amber alert.
Dave seemed nice at first he was handsome had a lot of money
many called him the king of the ring and a true business
mogul mogu middle-class what if it is that I don't know how
that to me that seems like that seems like a lot of money
though no I believed him when he told me he knew my father
and promised to take good care of me give me a job and
everything I had no idea he'd make my life a living hell in
a matter of weeks someone had to deal with him let's just
say he didn't manage to defend his championship championship
belt at the last fight and since trash won't take itself out
i needed to handle this mr kovalski like in the good old
days xo xo amber
we have three giant locations
question the community ones are these the nightmare levels
or or is amber's the nightmare levels is amber an act 2 I
know she's so nice right nightmare is at oh none of them oh
don't forget to change your skill thank you
neither nightmare was alright is our revised act Act one.
So if I go to the truck...
Challenges are now available.
What?
Oh my gosh.
This one is small.
Let's try it.
Wait, location size 3.
Hold on.
Let's do it.
Location size.
Small, small, small, small, small.
Wait, so if I do a challenge, is that it?
Is Amber killed 12 feet?
Pull over it for real.
Look at the modern art one.
This one.
Amber is act two.
Got it.
So what are the, uh...
What are the...
Look at the nightmare tab.
Am I crazy?
I don't see...
Oh, here!
Oh!
Was it previous?
And then there's true cleaner!
Use your experience to clean the crime scenes you're already
familiar with.
No cleaner sense and limited upgrades.
Screw that.
Wait, let's do one then.
Let's do one of the smaller size ones.
And then...
Reward.
Wait, hold on.
This one's the smallest size.
Toxic love.
Oh, it's this place.
Um...
This one was pretty big, though, no?
Which one was this?
Trial?
Oh, this is the spa.
Okay.
It says this one's small, but I don't believe it.
This was Tyler's house.
Oh, we can get the cat!
We'll try it.
We'll try this one.
It'll be a long...
see how it's any different oh my god Tyler really wanted to
get his life together oh oh my god hello Johnny hello I like
he's talking about Tyler this is literally like a cat's home
this is so oh my god oh my headphones please
You can't walk through anywhere.
You have to duck.
It's like a cat.
Oh my god, the scratching post!
This is kitty heaven!
Treeto!
Minto!
Oh my god, the shower has been turned into a cat.
Oh my gosh, outside!
It's all fish!
Oh, wow, Johnny.
Look, look at all the stuff.
You see it?
Stop it.
Cleaning procedures started.
Oh my gosh.
What do you...
What does that mean?
These are the furnitures that need to be moved, but...
I'm starting to get hungry though guys so is Johnny.
Maybe we save this for next time.
Let's get rid of that.
The floor looks interesting, but I can't work like that.
Now that we have nightmare, we can just kind of do it
whenever we want, which is fun.
I didn't really have a lunch, so...
The music is tripping me up.
Meow, meow, meow, meow, meow.
But this game is so addicting too, no?
Like, I just, when I start, I don't want to stop.
It's so fun.
Game is so fun.
Wait, where did he?
Oh, no, he put him down.
What happened to you?
I feel like I'm in a fever dream.
I mean, I am in a fever dream.
Did these go up here?
Where do they go?
Oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh.
Speaking of, is it okay to clip that one moment from
yesterday?
You know the one.
Clip from yesterday.
The member stream.
Why, Donnie?
Tommy!
sure go ahead what dignity do I have left I'm already a
vtuber what dignity do I have left I've thrown it all away
okay Johnny you're being actually such a problem you cannot
be that hungry you cannot be that hungry he's very he acts
like he's truly one of those types of cats it's like I've
never eaten before I've eaten before you know i wonder if
this one has the secret too what's in here wait what's that
wait there's a whole other room
how do i get it out there we go
can i go in
was it like that before i don't remember oh what's this Ugh!
I
made some bad decisions.
Then my life became messier than your litter box.
Marla.
I can't be with you forever.
These are some nice places for litter boxes too.
Wait, what was that?
Anyways, guys, we did finish Act 1.
I might take a little bit of a break before Act 2.
And then probably also for some of the nightmare levels.
We can just do them sometimes, like, you know, however many
we want.
A couple levels in, like, You know, Halloween time.
So...
Yeah, I think that'll be good.
There's so many boxes.
Oh my gosh, human organs.
So we'll just do that, where...
Um, we'll take a break for Act 2.
Obviously, I do want to play it.
I definitely recommend doing Toxic Love and Italian job
around that time.
Yeah, yeah!
If you guys have any level...
I mean, if you guys have any levels that you'd like to see,
feel free to suggest.
We're really loving these streams.
I'm so down to act to the nightmare levels and even DLC when
you feel up to it.
Hope you and Johnny have a good meal.
Thank you, Marilyn!
Yeah, I've been enjoying...
I thought we were going to beat the game, so I'm pleasantly
surprised.
I mean, I knew that there were the nightmare levels, but I'm
pleasantly surprised.
I got things for the beat!
Now that he has a secret layer in his basement, Amber should
have summoned Kovalski by holding up a mop and...
in front of a search light.
They are truly the Batman of our city, huh?
This guy.
Yeah.
But we'll pick this up.
We'll do the, we'll finish these nightmare levels.
Or maybe not finished, but we'll do a bunch of them, you
know.
For Halloween time for spooky month and check it out.
Check out more.
And then Act 2 again we'll be like a little bit it's just I
have other games I want to play so fake me thank you not the
cleaner we deserve but the cleaner we need I think we
deserve well no we don't deserve Kovalski he's too good he's
too good this is so funny why is he dreaming about this
anyway I'm curious how that cat level is now the one that
had the actual cat ghost this could be a cool wallpaper
raiders oh hello thank you thank you sorry I keep missing
all the raid notice there we go thank you for the five get
the thank you thank you well I hope you guys enjoyed um
power what not power oh my gosh um not power wash uh crime
scene cleaner and i'm gonna go get some food and i recommend
you guys get some yummy food as well you had a lot of raids
today right it is a good view it is i wish we could open the
window all the way
look at all the fish just finished eating yummy and you
didn't let me bless your meal lance thank you so much for
the five get there you didn't let me bless your meal Well,
for everybody who has not eaten that, here is your moi moi
beam, too!
Make your food so delicious and nutritious and amazing!
Oishiknaare!
Thank you, everyone!
Bye-bye!
Otsuminto, Otsuminto, it'suminto, it's time!
Bye-bye, thank you, thank you!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Bye-bye!